the maesters tell us that
aegon came to westeros with fire and
blood
and hammered six kingdoms into one
fire he undoubtedly brought as the kings
of the rock
reach and iron islands learned aegon's
own son
maegor the cruel was killed by the very
iron throne his father had forged
if you believe the tales if you don't
then perhaps the cruel
is not a wise name for a king to earn
darren first of his name tried to finish
his ancestors work and bring dawn into
the fold
for his efforts he lost 60 000 men
and his own life of 18 years
during the great targaryen civil war
known as the dance of the dragons
a king and queen each vied for the
throne
dividing their house and its dragons
against each other
eventually the queen was fed to her
rival's dragon while her son watched
and the victorious king soon died of his
own wounds
by the war's end king's landing was
smashed cities raised and sacked
never to be rebuilt and dragons had
faded from this world
for centuries the kingsguard had been
the glory of the realm
aegon the conqueror had established the
order as his personal guardians after
uniting westeros with fire and blood
he knew that some of his subjects
wouldn't take to conquest
and his dragons were no use against
knives in the dark
no doubt surrounding himself with the
greatest knights in westeros made his
rule more palatable and less foreign as
well
everyone in his kingdom soon knew the
names and sung the songs of the
kingsguard
i certainly did from earliest days
there was one king's guard i forgot the
bastard's name
who swore an oath to his dying targaryen
king to crown his daughter after him
the very night that king died this
kingsguard crowned the king's son
instead
when an old man on the small council
dared to protest this honorable knight
opened his throat bastard died in a very
civil war he started
along with the old king's son daughter
and most of their dragons
and the kingsguard all that duty and
honor and not enough brains to figure
out which targaryen to give it to
twin brothers even ended up on opposite
sides died with tears on their cheeks as
they cut each other down
i suppose i should think that's tragic
but stupid men do stupid things every
day
and nobody cries over them as little
more than a boy
sir kristen cole replaced the legendary
sirayam redwine on the king's guard and
soon rose to lord commander
but knights only know one way to settle
disputes
when prince aegon's father died sir
kristen slit the throat of an advisor
who objected to aegon's ascension over
his aunt the anointed heir
his actions so pleased the new king
aegon second of his name
that he appointed sir christian as his
hand in the ensuing civil war
called the dance of dragons neither sir
christian
nor the king nor even the targaryen
dragons would survive it
the targaryen dynasty united the seven
kingdoms and
lasted nearly three centuries it was a
dynasty
forged in fire sealed in blood and
destroyed by rebellion
the targaryens are blood of the dragon
descended from the nobility
of ancient valyria a once mighty empire
in the east
when the cataclysmic doom laid waste of
valyria and its people
the targaryens survived having settled
on the island fortress of dragonstone
years before
they remained there for a century until
the rise
of aegon the conqueror instead of
attempting to reclaim the eastern lands
of his ancestors
aegon sailed west for the seven kingdoms
his sisters visenya and rhaenys at his
side
to keep the bloodlines pure aegon
continued the custom of his valyrian
ancestors and took
both of his sisters to wife together
they came ashore on the eastern coast of
westeros
their blazon a dragon with three heads
representing aegon and his sister wives
their words fire and blood
their host was small in comparison to
the armies of westeros that awaited them
aegon and his sisters had a secret
weapon
the last of the dragons
he conquered every kingdom save dawn
which eventually bowed to targaryen rule
a century later
he had the swords of his enemies melted
down by the fiery breath of his dragon
valerian the black dread
and forged into the iron throne
the capital city of king's landing was
built on the eastern coast
where aegon and his sisters first came
ashore
and aegon ordered the construction of a
royal castle on its highest hill
the red keep aegon built his castle of
red rock
to remind people of the fires he'd
roasted his enemies in
so whenever king's landing locked up
they'd see the price of defiance
he knew the first rule of kings only
fear keeps men in line
fear and punishment
then again torture chambers are just so
private better to punish your enemies
where everyone can see and remember
like the targaryen who forced his nephew
to watch
as he fed the boy's traitor mother to a
dragon
oh what i could do with a dragon
the stories claimed that the old way
died with her and the black and his sons
at harrenhal
our ships and axes were no match for
aegon's dragons
so our ancestors bend their steel into
fishhooks
and our kingdom into villages and
started telling the red
tails around the fire of how we used to
be strong
and how one day would be so again
generations later
a young boy listened to them dalton
greyjoy
the wild young heir to pike was rowing
at five and reaving at 10
in the basilisk isles with his uncle by
dalton had sailed as far as old geese
fought in a dozen battles and claimed
four salt wives
in his fifteenth year he avenged his
uncle's death in battle
but he took a dozen wounds and emerged
from the fight
drenched head to heel and blood
from that day forth men called him
the red kraken during the dance of
dragons
the red kraken picked the side that was
fighting the lannisters
and fell upon the westerlands while the
lannisters were up at war
casterly rock itself proved too strong
once the lady of the castle barred its
gates
but the ironborn burned the lannister
fleet and
sacked lannisport carrying off gold
grain and hundreds of women and girls
including lord lannister's favorite
mistress and all his bastards
the red kraken now ruled the sunset sea
as his forebears had and his longships
again brought the old way to the coast
of westeros
but then the war ended and the mainland
armies came home
the iron throne commanded the red kraken
to stop breathing
and when he didn't a mistress opened his
throat as he slept
while his son squabbled the lannisters
send their soldiers to the iron islands
thousands of men women and children were
put to the sword
and scores of villages and hundreds of
longships
were put to the torch the glorious
return to the old way
had lasted almost two years
in its time the dragon pit was a marvel
of the world
full-grown targaryen dragons nested
beneath its massive dome
and even on the darkest nights the walls
seemed to glow
with the fire of the great beasts inside
as had the site's previous occupant
the sept of remembrance when maegor the
crow blasted it with dragon fire during
morning prayers
the screams of the dying men echoed
through king's landing all day
and a pool of ash and smoke hung over
the city for a week
but as it dissipated so too did the
rebellion of the faith militant
the sept of remembrance faded from
memory
and maegor decided to replace a monument
to the gods
with a monument to his family the dragon
pit
labor proved elusive however for after
the red keep was finished
maegor had hosted a three-day feast for
all the builders stonemasons and
carpenters
who had worked to build it at its
conclusion
he slaughtered them so that only he
would know the castle secrets
so many men fled the construction of the
dragonpit
but maegor was forced to employ the
prisoners of the city dungeons
supplemented by skilled and ignorant
builders
from across the narrow sea
for more than a century the targaryens
housed their dragons in the dragon pit
the dragons are not horses to be stabled
or hounds to be candled
with each generation the dragons became
less less massive less swift
less long-lived and
less invulnerable during the dance of
dragons
two targaryen factions killed a handful
of their families dragons while fighting
each other
a frenzied mob even broke into the
dragonpit
and slaughtered the five dragons chained
there though
the last managed to bring down the roof
of the great dome
on its assailants the dragons never
recovered their former strength
or numbers perhaps their line had been
too broken
or perhaps others intervened to break it
further
but the last dragon grew no larger than
a cat and its death
earned aegon third of his name the
epithet
dragon bay
you